مطار جوستمر في همم الواقع في مدينه
كوستاميل الشمال العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
كان احد المواقع الاستراتيجيه والاهداف
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه قبل
انسحابها نعم بالفعل وصلت القوات الروسيه
الى هذا المكان وكذلك همم خلفت اثار
الدمار التي نرصدها الان عبر الكاميرا
العربيه وواحده منها عمليات الدمار هي
لطائره الشحن وهي اكبر طائره شحن في
العالم وهي من نوع
225 والتي دمرتها طبعا هذه الطائره التي
تستطيع حمل اكثر من 250 طن من عمليات
الشحن وايضا يصل طولها الى اكثر من 84
مترا تحمل همم ست محركات كل محركات يزن
اكثر من همم خمسه الاف كلغ
من همم كوزن طبعا همم اعمال التدمير وايضا
الحطام الذي نشاهده الان هي هذه الطائره
التي كان قد اصدر بيان سابق من شركه
انتونيفلي عن هذه الطائره التي كانت تبددت
منها احلام العديد من الشركات التي كانت
تقوم بعمليات الشحن طبعا ما نشاهد الان هو
النصف او مؤخره الطائره اما امام الطائره
والنصف الاخر الامامي هو في الجهه
المقابله الان وهي من الحطام سواء مكسوره
الطائره ومقدمه الطائره او كذلك الجزء
الخلفي بنسبه لها دمر تماما همم في همم
لهذه الطائره طبعا ايضا هناك عدد من
العمليات التدمير التي خلفتها القوات
الروسيه قبل انسحابها من المطار هو لتدمير
برج المراه المراقبه لمطار جوستميله والتي
ترصده كاميرا عربيه لاول مره هذه من ايضا
بعض همم
عمليه التجميل سواء لبرج المراقبه او لك
لاحد الهناجر الخاصه للطائرات والتي تم
تدميرها من قبل القوات الروسيه طبعا
المدرج في هذا المطار هو دمر تدميرا جزئيا
ولكن الان ايضا الحكومه الاوكرانيه همم
قامت بعمليه اعاده تاهيل وكذلك عمليه زفله
لهذا المدرج وكذلك ايضا نشاهد فريق من
شركه انتونيف تقوم باعمال الصيانه وترميم
لهذه الطائره
ان تعيد ما خلفته القوات الروسيه من
عمليات التجميل طبعا شركه انتنوف صرح
الرئيس تنفيذي لها يوم امس ان هناك ايضا
طائره اخرى تقوم بتصنيعها مشابهه لهذه
الطائره ولكن حتى الان لم يتم معرفه ما
اذا كانت صناعه هذه الطائره سوف تكون داخل
اوكرانيه
المعلومات التي نقلتها الينا من همم داخل
مطار جسمهم اكبر طائره في العالم التي
دمرتها القوه الروسيه وفد العربيه هاني
صفير شكرا لك